is our experiment conducted in the US
could be about to break new ground in
neuroscience but also raise some serious
ethical questions at the same time after
scientists managed to partially revived
activity in a dead pigs brain
researchers at Yale University managed
to restore some cellular functions
apparently for hours after the animal's
death
they say the brain showed no sign of
consciousness and stressed that if they
had that test would have been stopped
immediately they say scientists further
claim the study could advance treatment
for human brain damage and disease and
prove that a most important organ as the
capacity to still be active post mortem
these findings demonstrate that under
appropriate conditions the isolated
intact large mammalian brain possesses
an underappreciated capacity for
restoration of micro circulation and
molecular and cellular activity after a
prolonged post-mortem interval we got to
embrace change good plan or not we spoke
to neuroscientist and animal behavior
expert Lorri Moreno along with the
program director from scientists for the
EU my girls worthy I'm here you've
actually got I think it was 32 pigs
brains from an abattoir so they'd
already been killed and used for another
purpose and so that is more ethically
sound and then we get on to the question
of that is ethically sound to try and
revive these brains and an important
thing that you need to know from the
study was that they made every effort
and succeeded in not having the neural
activity coming back so the brain wasn't
actually firing away like it usually
does sure it there's no coordinated
neural activity but they wouldn't do it
on their aunt Tilly were they and I'm
also reminded of the fact that there's a
lot of research now growing research
that you know in humans when humans are
considered clinically dead and are then
revived that there is some evidence for
consciousness so we really don't know
what's going on here and is is very
dangerous territory there isn't a lot
there that actually alarms me personally
that that would be my personal judgement
or but in this area it is about
judgement calls and so clearly if you
starting to move into this area you do
what we always do in science where you
say this is a new area let's get
together globally let's sit down let's
say what's acceptable and what's not
here's the problem from my point of view
that whenever humans think about this
there are very few ways in which the
research subjects the animals the pigs
in this case have any standing in the
issue and generally what we do in
science is you know as we do what's
convenient we do what's good for us and
we we try to forget all the rest of that
stuff so who is going to stand up for
these animals who are being subjected to
a manipulation that even the the primary
authors say we're really not sure what
is going on given that these particular
animals themselves that are already
being killed because they were already
going to be thrown on someone's barbecue
then the fact that you would then want
to understand the cellular mechanisms of
the brain that the pig share and we
share and all other mammals share and
understand that further empowering us in
order to save not just ourselves other
animals
you